un champ où il n'y a ni bleynie colza
nous fleurissent les roquettes nous
sommes dans la région agricole doubad il
y a quelques semaines il frappe russe a
touché de plein fouet en dépôt d'armes
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous voyez c'est le résultat de
l'explosion du pouvoir des blocs c'est
ce qu'il reste du dépôt d'armes on voit
aussi des roquettes qui était dans le
dépôt d'armes non loin d'ici
oserais-je est un représentant important
de la filière agricole dans la région
ici les agriculteurs peuvent continuer à
travailler ils ne sont pas mobilisés
pour aller au front ils produisent pour
nourrir le pays en guerre aux côtés
d'andrei en cela d'un riche propriétaire
terrien qui a fui la ville de carson son
contrôle russe il achète avec ses
propres deniers en slovaquie ou
l'autriche des 4,4 pour les ramener en
ukraine et les offrir à l'armée qui les
transforme en véhicules militaires
pendant des années en tant qu'exploitant
agrigole j'ai fait des profits
j'espérais investir cet argent dans mon
exploitation mais j'ai compris qu'il n'y
avait plus d'espoir mais ferme alors la
meilleure façon de dépenser mon argent
c'est d'aider l'armée craignant
la région d'où vannes et à pois de
passage pour les réfugiés qui fuient
l'est du pays comme jaroslav qui a dû
abandonner ses terres du côté de luz
pour le 'dow' basse
moi
j'ai mis toute mon âme 20 ans de ma vie
les économies dans ce business je ne
veux pas perdre tout cela je veux y
retourner avec ma famille
jaroslav espère retrouver ses terres en
attendant il participe à aider ceux qui
fuient les combats
ces femmes sont récemment arrivées de la
région du donbass
ma ville n'a pas encore été détruites
mais ça va venir
nous avons une situation critique on a
été bombardé dès le début de la guerre
toutes nos maisons sont détruits presque
toute la ville a été détruite tout est
réduit en cendres ce soir ces femmes
vont dormir dans une école transformée
en refuge en caressant l'espoir de
retourner un jour chez elle
à ou bad et dans les régions agricoles
du centre du pays les paysans continuent
de travailler de produire il accueille
aussi un certain nombre d'exploitants
qui ont fui l'est du pays sous le feu
des bombes russe il multiplie également
les initiatives pour participer à
l'effort de guerre